guten tag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz und herzlich
willkommen auch allen die uns heute
zuschauen da diese pressekonferenz live
übertragen wird
ich sage noch ein paar kurze worte damit
sie wissen was das hier ist was sie hier
sehen es ist eine veranstaltung der
bundespressekonferenz die
bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation der
journalistinnen und journalisten die
über den bundestag und über die
bundesregierung berichten
wir gewährleisten dass alle mitglieder
die inländischen der
bundespressekonferenz und die
ausländischen die im verein der
auslandspresse mitglied sind hier fragen
stellen können
wir freuen uns dass wir die vertreter
der regierung die sprecher der regierung
bei uns hier haben können dass sie vor
allen dingen auch in diesen tagen zu uns
kommen und unsere fragen beantworten
in besonderen zeiten erlauben wir eine
live übertragung dieser veranstaltung
weil wir wissen dass das interesse und
das informationsbedürfnis groß ist und
herzlichen dank an phoenix die uns mit
zwei gebärdendolmetscher rinnen
unterstützen
vielen dank dafür ja sie haben aus dem
kabinett zu bricht ja mache ich auch
gleich gerne guten tag meine damen und
herren ich wollte zwei dinge vorweg
sagen erst wenn es um erstens haben sie
ja sicherlich auch die ankündigung
bekommen dass die bundeskanzlerin heute
nachmittag um 16 uhr 15 im kanzleramt
vor die presse treten wird ich weiß noch
mal daraufhin wegen der nötigen
abstandsregelungen haben wir den etwas
begrenzten zugang den sie ja auch aus
den letzten wochen schon kennen aber
natürlich wird auch alles live im netz
zu sehen sein 16.15 noch mal kurz
unterbrechen wir sind hier heute
limitiert auf eine stunde bei und 14 uhr
nur jahr für die kollegen um 14 uhr
genau
bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
bundesfinanzminister zu uns kommen
entscheidung ja ich wollte noch einmal
ganz kurz
einleitend sagen wir sind jetzt in der
karwoche wir gehen auf das osterfest zu
ist eine ganz besondere zeit für alle ob
sie nun christen sind oder nicht und es
eine zeit die wir alle in diesem jahr
der korona pandemie ganz anders erleben
werden und erleben müssen die
bundeskanzlerin hat in ihrem podcast am
wochenende die lage ja noch mal
beschrieben sie sprach von der leichten
hoffnung die sich mit den neuen
infektionszahlen verbindet von denen wir
aber eben noch nicht sagen können ob sie
wirklich einen sicheren trend abbilden
es bleibt daher absolut notwendig alle
regeln der rede des reduzierten
öffentlichen lebens wie des reduzierten
privaten lebens weiter einzuhalten es
bleibt unerlässlich den abstand von
mindestens eineinhalb metern zu allen zu
waren mit ausnahme derjenigen menschen
mit denen man in der wohnung
zusammenlebt es bleibt daher für jeden
von uns bei der notwendigkeit
regelmäßigen und gründlichen
händewaschens also all diese
hygieneregeln sind heute so nützlich und
notwendig wie in den letzten wochen auch
und das wird auch so bleiben und vieles
das uns an ostern wichtig und lieb ist
der kirchgang die kurze urlaubsreise der
ausflug ans meer der ausflug in die
berge mit vielen anderen ums osterfeuer
stehen das geht in diesem jahr eben
nicht das soll bitte jeder wissen und
das soll bitte jeder auch beherzigen
insofern werden sie verstehen dass die
bundesregierung auch wenn manche das
fordern jetzt keinen exit stichtag
keinen festen termin nennen kann ab dem
alles wieder anders wird ab dem die
maßnahmen gelockert werden können
die kanzlerin hat aber in diesem podcast
auch an alle bürger und bürgerinnen die
versicherung gegeben dass sie und die
gesamte bundesregierung jeden tag
darüber nachdenken wie beides zu
schaffen sein wird also sowohl den
gesundheitsschutz für alle zu sichern
als auch einen prozess auszusetzen mit
dem das öffentliche leben schritt für
schritt wieder möglich wird
und jetzt komme ich zu dem schon
angesprochenen treffen der
bundeskanzlerin mit einigen ministern
zum umgang mit der pandemie das findet
ja nun all montag lich statt
und auch am donnerstag dann werden je
nach thema weitere minister hinzugezogen
heute ging es im wesentlichen um
folgende themen und die kollegen aus den
ressorts können
da sicherlich dann auch noch
einzelheiten geben zunächst hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister ein
lagebericht zum stand der pandemie in
deutschland abgegeben unter anderem auch
zur situation in den krankenhäusern die
natürlich regional sehr unterschiedlich
ist
der bundesinnenminister hat dann über
fragen die mit der einreise nach
deutschland verbunden sind gesprochen
und vorschläge gemacht die wiederum mit
den ländern zu beraten sind denn bei
denen liegen kompetenzen in diesem
bereich
es geht im kern darum jetzt da das lka
nicht mehr einzelne länder als
risikogebiet ausweist eine
vorgehensweise zu finden die für
einreisende aus allen ländern die
gleiche ist ein weiteres wichtiges thema
ebenfalls vom gesundheitsminister
vorgetragen ist das thema der heimischen
produktion von schutzausrüstung
besonders masken diese produktion ist
wiederum nur möglich wenn
ausgangsmaterial wie eine spezielle art
von vlies auch hier in deutschland
hergestellt werden und darum bemüht sich
das bundesgesundheitsministerium und
abschließend ging es in dieser
besprechung der kanzlerin mit den
ministern um das thema zusätzliche
hilfen für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen mittels eines kfw- schnell
kredit dazu kommen ja um 14 uhr die
minister scholz und altmaier hier in die
bpk und bericht nehmen
das war es von ihrer seite
ich schlage vor wir gehen mal der
reihenfolge der dem kabinett nach zum
thema gesundheit alles was um sich um
gesundheit und beschaffung betrifft
haring gekittet
das hat der jungen hotel zahlen das sind
steht der besten goalies ist 30.000 das
allein reicht
zu diesen zahlen wird am wochenende also
man muss unterscheiden die eben das eine
sind die zahlen die zusagen die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft bei ihren
krankenhäusern abgefragt hat und das
andere sind die zahlen die in dem sogar
die register gemeldet werden
das ist ein register dass die zusagen
fachgesellschaft aufgestellt hat und da
melden die krankenhäuser ihre zur
verfügung stehenden intensiv und
beatmungs betten hin
dieses register besteht schon seit
einiger zeit da waren also jetzt am
wochenende waren und da waren sich
glaube ich auch beide beide
gesellschaften einig dass ungefähr in
deutschland 10.000 beatmungs betten frei
sind also zur verfügung stehen um dem
und den überblick sozusagen zu
verstetigen und um einen noch besseren
überblick zu bekommen gibt es jetzt eine
einer anordnung oder ist auf den weg
gebracht worden eine anordnung von
gesundheitsminister sparen dass die
krankenhäuser verpflichtet werden diese
betten an das register zu melden und
zwar sollen die täglich gemeldet werden
um sozusagen täglich einen aktuellen
überblick zu haben
da kann ich ihnen vielleicht auch noch
eine aktuelle zahl zu geben
stand heute es geht um 1160
krankenhäuser und davon haben stand
heute 1000 und 15 freie betten gemeldet
also das ist die zahl der krankenhäuser
noch nicht erteilt
so das ist das eine und der andere punkt
war also dieser diese nationale fertig
also das ist eine forderung die jetzt
auch nicht so ganz neu ist dies auch
letzte woche vorletzte woche schon mal
erhoben worden
also wir sind eigentlich der meinung
dass eine sozialen eine bundes eine
bundesbehörde oder eine zentrale
bundesweite verteilung da nicht so viel
sinn macht es ist aus unserer sicht
besser dass bei den ländern zugelassen
die einfach den überblick über ihre
krankenhäuser haben und sozusagen ihr
bei im bedarfsfall dort tätig werden
können also ich keinen moment ich kann
ich jetzt nicht genau die zahl der
betten sagen ich kann ihnen nur wenn die
zahl der krankenhäuser sagen und diese
10.000 betten um die die man am
wochenende da identifiziert hat von
beiden seiten übereinstimmend
dieses register als öffentlich einsehbar
also da bitte ich um verständnis dass
ich dazu im moment keinen aktuellen
stand habe weil das halt wirklich auch
sehr sehr schnellen veränderungen
unterworfen ist ja der referentenentwurf
ist jetzt sozusagen im weg gebracht
worden also das ganz so schlecht ist
jetzt auch nicht aber das kommt dann
also mensch ins hat noch freiwillige
meldungen der krankenhäuser aber auch
verlässlich aber halt sind noch nicht
für alle krankenhäuser da ich denke also
ich kann ihnen das nicht sagen das ist
eine verordnung die jetzt vorgelegt
werden muss und ich muss halt
unterzeichnet werden verkündet werden
und dann tritt in kraft ja also es gibt
sozusagen eine initiative des
gesundheitsministeriums wir haben die
die deutschen unternehmen angeschrieben
die schon vorher sozusagen signalisiert
haben dass sie bereit sind zu
produzieren angeschrieben und ihnen
sozusagen einen rahmenvertrag angeboten
um ihnen da auch eine gewisse sicherheit
zu geben das ist ein rahmenvertrag der
bis ende 2021 laufen soll und hat
bestimmte bedingungen konditionen für
die abnahme der der des materials bietet
wie viele unternehmen sich bis sagen der
welt haben kann ich ihnen heute nicht
sagen aber es gibt ja ich meine das ist
ja auch öffentlich bekannt es gibt
einige deutschen unternehmen die da
schon eingestiegen sind die schon
produzieren die sich da schon öffentlich
dazu geäußert haben
trigema unter anderem
ja dass das wissen sie ja auch wir sind
natürlich jetzt schon mit allen kräften
dabei material einzukaufen im inland und
im ausland das ist auch ein laufender
prozess der wird natürlich jeden tag
werden der lieferung gestellt und die
führung entgegen genommen
den den deutschen hersteller also diese
rahmenverträge haben eine frist dass man
sagt man sie bis mitte august müssen die
ersten lieferungen da sein
also setzt man voraus das ist jetzt auch
erstmal anlaufen muss dass die
produktion eingestellt werden muss und
bis dahin sollen die ersten lieferungen
garantiert werden aber auch jetzt ist es
natürlich schon so dass viel geliefert
wird ich kann ihnen da auch noch ein
paar aktuelle zahlen geben also ende
letzter woche hatten wir lieferungen von
von schutzmasken also geht es einmal um
diese diese ffp masken und die
sogenannten op masken hatten wir masse
sind lieferungen von 7 knapp 37
millionen stück eingegangen die dann
verteilt werden auf die bundesländer das
waren die masken und ungefähr knapp
knapp 25 millionen handschuhe und das
ist ein laufender prozess da wird jeden
tag bestellt und geliefert
ich glaube man muss entschuldigung ich
das so sage ich glaube man muss eben im
blick haben dass es nicht nur um einen
kurzfristigen bedarf geben wird was
masken und schutzausrüstung betrifft
sondern auch einen mittelfristigen
bedarf und deswegen ist es wichtig hier
in deutschland eben auch eine
mittelfristige produktion aufzubauen die
diesen bedarf dann in den kommenden
monaten
und das wird um viele monate gehen auch
decken kann
ich habe jetzt auf meiner liste
auf jeden fall sie und herrn lange
eine frage noch die uns online von den
kollegen zugespielt wurde
und dann wird das thema gerne wechseln
wenn es hier noch großen bedarf gibt
frau münch weil wir noch sehr viele
fragen auch zu exit strategie und
grenzkontrollen haben es gibt hier eine
frage von der kollegin rita zu in den
intensivbetten 10.000 neue betten fragt
sie so hat sie das verstanden und wie
war die gesagt der gesamten zeit stand
am wochenende ja wie gesagt das habe ich
ja eben schon gesagt also am wochenende
gab es von von vom aus diesem register
und von der krankenhausgesellschaft die
die meldung dass zehntausende ordnungs
betten zur verfügung stehen insgesamt
10.000 sozusagen sind sind frei und
stehen stehen für aufnahme zufällig ganz
genau sehen wann die frage rein kommt ob
die vor ihrer antwort oder nach ihrer
antwort reingekommen ist die verzögerung
zu entscheiden herr jung bist der
nächste
der bericht ist mit übernehmen
[Musik]
also ich weiß dass herr wähler das am
freitag so dargestellt hat
dass die reproduktionsrate ungefähr 1
beträgt also das heißt dass ein
infizierte person ungefähr eine weitere
person ansteckt und also diese
reproduktionsrate wird deshalb als
wichtig betrachtet weil wir davon
ausgeht dass erst also dass sie
praktisch unter 1 fallen muss um
wirklich einen stabilen trend zu haben
und auch über weitere maßnahmen
nachdenken
na ja also das ist das sind zahlen die
das lka den tag neu berechnet und
insofern halten wir die für belastbar
hab ich jetzt moment keine aktuelle zahl
aber vielleicht bekomme ich gleich ein
dann geht es mit ihnen weiter bitte
können sie das mikrofon wahrnehmen weil
dann sind sie wirklich auch für die die
nicht im soll sind viel besser zu
verstehen danke naja die die lage ist er
bekannt wie die wie sich sozusagen wie
wie sich die fallzahlen verteilen
insgesamt gibt es also stand heute neben
rk ii gemeldet
95 1391 infizierte fälle die sich halt
auf die bundesländer fatalen schwerpunkt
ist nach wie vor baden württemberg
nordrhein westfalen und bayern hat die
meisten meisten infizierten fälle im
moment also da kann ich ihnen jetzt wo
man kein aktuellen stand geben also ich
habe da keine sozusagen landes
landesbezogenen meldungen vorliegen
dann geht's weiter mit herrn lange
herr scholz hatte gestern die schlüssel
zweite frage nein die technik also
zweite frage nein das war heute kein
thema und die inländische produktion ja
das war heute thema in gestalt dieses
unter themas über das wir hier
gesprochen haben für eine inländische
produktion von schutzmasken muss
gewährleistet sein dass wichtige
vorprodukte eben auch in deutschland
verfügbar und in deutschland hergestellt
sind und genau das prüft das
gesundheitsministerium im moment wie man
mit den unternehmen die dafür in frage
kommen sozusagen verabredungen treffen
kann wie man sie bei den
investitionskosten unterstützen kann wie
man auch garantie abnahmen vereinbart
damit sich die investition in diese
produktion die diese unternehmen bisher
nicht machen
auch rechnet
[Musik]
also ich kann ihnen dazu erst gar keine
zahlen nennen das läuft also von der
organisation von der verteilung her
so läuft das nicht aber es bleiben die
entschuldigung ich bin hier gramms
multitasking ja ich kann ihnen gerne die
zahlen nennen sie mir vorliegen wie sie
wissen wird er sehr gut organisiert und
die länder machen bestimmte zusagen auf
basis der jeweils vorliegenden
kapazitäten die da sind die zur
verfügung gestellt werden können für
patienten aus krisengebieten des anderen
ländern europas
da sind wir so weit gekommen ist haben
bisher bei 198 patienten aus anderen eu
mitgliedsstaaten davon 130 aus
frankreich 44 aus italien und 24 aus den
niederlanden bislang gibt es auch
weitere 58 platz zu sagen von denen wir
derzeit kenntnis haben die noch nicht
gefüllt sind
dazu gibt es gespräche und die klar zu
sagen werden auch nicht mehr so wie es
am anfang war exklusiv für bestimmte eu
länder vergeben sondern gelten allgemein
für andere eu staaten von der
italienischen seite ist es im moment so
dass ein leichter rückgang der zahl der
korona intensiv patienten zu beobachten
es daher und wird aus italien zunächst
kein weiterer transfer nach deutschland
geplant die bundestags informiert und
stehen weiter bereit falls die
lage-einschätzung da ändern sollte würde
das thema gerne verlassen jetzt es gibt
einige fragen zum thema lockerung exit
strategie und die fragen der
grenzkontrolle goffert wir haben das so
[Musik]
ja vielleicht fange ich kurz an
mit ihrer frage nach der exit strategie
ich verweise nochmal auf den podcast
denen die bundeskanzlerin am wochenende
gemacht hat über den ja auch sehr viel
berichtet wurde und der von sehr vielen
bürgern auch abgerufen wurde
sie hat ganz klar gesagt die bürger
können sich darauf verlassen dass die
bundesregierung ihrer verantwortung
nachkommt und tag und nacht wie sie
gesagt hat darüber nachdenkt wie wir
beides zusammenbringen das hohe ziel des
gesundheitsschutzes was nichts anderes
heißt als dass für jeden bürger der
schwer erkrankt mit corona ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert werden muss
auch wirklich die adäquate behandlung zu
sichern können und auf der anderen seite
den notwendigen prozess das öffentliche
leben wieder schritt für schritt in gang
zu setzen
darüber denkt die bundesregierung nach
natürlich ist wäre unverantwortlich wenn
sie es nicht täten die bundeskanzlerin
hat aber auch gesagt dass es
unverantwortlich wäre wenn sie jetzt
falsche hoffnungen wecken würde die sich
dann durch die realität der der dass das
infektionsgeschehen es möglicherweise
nicht erfüllen ließen deswegen können
wir jetzt hier heute keine exit
stichtage nennen und deswegen ist es
auch nicht sinnvoll jetzt über einzelne
mögliche schritte eines solchen
prozesses hier zu sprechen
ich mische mich weil gerade dazwischen
herr keller der kollege keller von rtl
n-tv hauptstadtstudio gefragt welche
erkenntnisse sie aus dem verhalten der
menschen an diesem sonnigen wochenende
unter den ausgangs regeln gezogen haben
und könnte man daraus womöglich eine
lockerung ableiten und frau vaters fragt
in österreich hat kannst redaktion
netzwerk deutschland fragt in österreich
hat kanzler kurz eine exit strategie
vorgestellt der feste daten für die
öffnung von geschäften vorsieht warum
sieht sich die bundesregierung dazu
nicht in der lage also zu der ersten
frage vielleicht kann auch das
innenministerium ergänzen ich habe
sicherlich jetzt nicht den
gesamtüberblick über alles was sich in
deutschland in der öffentlichkeit
zwischen schleswig holstein und dem
bodensee abgespielt hat es gilt dennoch
der eindruck und da habe ich auch nichts
gegenteiliges gehört dass die
allermeisten menschen in deutschland
nicht nur in umfragen erklären dass wir
diese maßnahmen für sinnvoll halten
sondern sich selber auch an diese
maßnahmen halten in ihrem persönlichen
leben in ihrer bewegung im öffentlichen
raum dass sie den abstand einhalten dass
sie die kontakte so minimieren wie es
nur irgend geht und dafür kann man den
allermeisten unserer mitbürger gar nicht
genug danken die bundeskanzlerin hat es
in ihrem podcast ja sehr deutlich getan
kein österreich ich bin jetzt der
sprecher der bundesregierung in
deutschland
sie waren ja angesprochen
bundesregierung sich nicht weil ich zu
der weil ich zu der frage des des exits
aus den derzeitigen lockerungen mit
bezug auf die dazu sehr klaren worte der
bundeskanzlerin mich geäußert hatte
in grenzen also ich kann allgemein zum
thema infektionswege nach deutschland
abbrechen folgendes sagen
ziel der maßnahmen der bundesregierung
seite aus der familie ist es ja die
ausbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen
und zwar dadurch dass man in deutschland
die infektionsketten durchbricht aber
auch die infektionswege nach deutschland
unterricht dazu sind verschiedene
maßnahmen ergriffen worden unter anderem
hat der europäische rat und 17 märz
beschlossen dass einreisen aus
drittstaaten in die eu nur noch in
ausgewählten fällen zulässig sind
das sind zb eu-bürger die einreisen
dürfen weiter bürger aus schengen
assoziierten staaten oder langjährig in
deutschland wohnende personen und deren
familien diesen ist nach wie vor die
einreise gestattet um an ihren wohnort
zurückzukehren und der
bundesinnenminister der auffassung dass
man hier noch weitere anstrengungen
unternehmen sollte und hat daher darauf
gedrungen dass im bundeskabinett hat
heute darüber gesprochen worden ist die
bundesregierung steckt den ländern
vor dass für diese personengruppe die
noch einreisen dürfen nach deutschland
nach mindestens mehrtägigen
auslandsaufenthalt eine verbindliche
zweiwöchiger quarantäne angeordnet
werden soll das ist nur ein das ist ein
vorschlag an die länder die dieses auf
basis des infektionsschutzgesetzes
anordnen oder die die aufgabe haben
dieses anzuordnen
der bund ist hier daran interessiert
dass er möglichst ein einheitliches
vorgehen haben und wird die länder daher
dabei unterstützen dieses umzusetzen
ich weiß dass da noch was offen ist es
gibt noch eine frage von der kollegin
janina lyko vom ard hörfunk zu den
grenzkontrollen wie viele personen
wurden an der grenze angewiesen war
schön sich das abgewiesen meinte
wahrscheinlich weil sie keinen triftigen
ein reisegrund hatten und wie viele
wurden wegen des verdachts auf eine
infektion abgewiesen
der wohl das interesse hat am 16 märz
angeordnet dass an einigen deutschen
binnengrenzen grenzkontrollen
vorübergehend wieder stattfinden sollten
und dann diesen grenzen
das sind die ganz österreich der schweiz
frankreich luxemburg und dänemark sind
bis zum 15 april insgesamt rund 70.000
personen abgewiesen worden die keinen
dringenden ein reisegrund nachweisen
konnten
ich habe ihn gerade die maßnahmen
vorgetragen die die bundesregierung
jetzt treffen möchte diese bestehen vor
allem darin dass personen die nach
deutschland einreisen mit einem
wichtigen grund sich 14 tage in
quarantäne begeben müssten weitere
maßnahmen sind stand heute nicht geplant
egal auf welchem wege diese personen
einreißen sei es auf dem landweg sei es
auf dem seeweg oder auch stimmt auf dem
luftweg es gilt für alle die nach
deutschland einreisen und einen
mehrtägigen auslandsaufenthalt hinter
sich haben
die kollegin von bouillon von der
süddeutschen zeitung fragt ob es
zutrifft dass es aus den staatskanzleien
der 16 bundesländern schon zustimmung
gab dass rückkehrer nach deutschland so
quarantäne verpflichtet werden sollen
das ist mir nicht bekannt ich bekannt so
dann mache ich hier also die app habe
ich noch im sinn gibt es nochmal jetzt
zu den grenzkontrollen bitteschön
ich kann ihnen mitteilen dass es
natürlich ausnahmen von dieser regelung
gilt unter anderem für berufspendler
aber auch für personen die also
geschäfts geschäftsreisen die drängenden
auf unaufschiebbare termine in
deutschland haben
es gilt auch für den für den
güterverkehr titel ausreisen es gilt für
transitreisende also nur durch
deutschland in der heimatland reisen
wollen und das nachweisen können für
diese soll diese zweiwöchige garantien
nicht gelten
ansonsten bleibt es dabei dass an
bestimmten grenzen vorübergehend ganz
motoren eingeführt worden sind dort kann
man unmittelbar dann kontrollieren ob
jemand einen dringend ein reisegrund hat
und wenn er den hat ihnen dann direkt
die quarantäne anordnung aushändigen die
bundespolizei wird hier unterstützen den
amtshilfe tätig werden die konkreten
einzelheiten denn jetzt in den nächsten
tagen mit den bundesländern abgestimmt
ziel ist das zum zehnten april diese
regelung in kraft treten der konkreten
frage wie sie wissen gibt es ja seit
beginn der pandemie in deutschland eine
intensivierte kontrollen
fahndungsmaßnahmen an allen grenzen auch
in denen an denen es keine
vorübergehenden ganz kontrolle
eingeführt worden sind und im rahmen
dieser kontrollmaßnahmen dieser
verstärkten hat die bundespolizei die
möglichkeit dann auch diese neue
quarantäne regelung mit zu überprüfen
und den personen eingereist sind die
container anordnung bekannt bekannt zu
machen ich habe hier noch zwei fragen
einmal die frage ab wann geht es und die
zweite frage ist wie kontrolliert wird
das kontrolliert die neue regelung soll
in abstimmung mit den bundesländern am
zehnten april in kraft treten und
konkrete einzelheiten werden jetzt
abgestimmt die bundespolizei wird den
anzieht tätig sein können um diese
anordnungen auszuhändigen kontrolliert
werden soll es durch die
gesundheitsbehörden vor ort die ja für
die umsetzung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes zuständig sind
wie gesagt diese verordnungen sollen auf
basis des infektionsschutzgesetzes
paragrafen 32a 28 erlassen werden durch
die länder
die dann auch für die umsetzung vor
allem zuständig sind
jetzt geht es frau besser noch eine
nachfrage bitte das würde ich jetzt mal
kurz in die schleife legen weil wir
sonst ich habe hier der hände und soweit
also sie sind jetzt erstmal dran nachdem
sie schon so lange gewartet
[Musik]
also zu ersten punkt kann ich sagen wie
gesagt in den nächsten tagen werden die
an konkreten einzelheiten einzelheiten
zusammen mit den bundesländern
festgelegt
es soll gelten dass für jeden der ein
reis aus dem genannten personenkreis
die verpflichtung gilt sich 14 tage in
häuslicher quarantäne zu begeben um
senkt umgesetzt werden diese maßnahmen
sollen die maßnahme durch die länder
werden auch kontrolliert werden so
studiert durch die gesundheitsbehörden
und die bundespolizei hat angeboten hier
in amtshilfe tätig zu sein und die diese
anordnung den personen auszuhändigen
an den grenzen in denen jetzt noch nicht
kontrolliert wird gibt es wie gesagt
diese verstärkten fahndungs- und
kontrollmaßnahmen und in diesem zuge
werden dann personen angehalten werden
auch wird an personen diese
bekanntmachen ausgehändigt werden können
aber die konkreten einzelheiten werden
jetzt bis zum 10 april ausgearbeitet und
da wird man dann wege finden wie das
kontrolliert werden ja die
bundeskanzlerin hat in diesem schon
erwähnten podcast sich an die bürger in
deutschland gewandt und hat ihnen ganz
klar gesagt mit der bitte ist ernst zu
nehmen das kurz reisen innerhalb
deutschlands all das was man in der
osterzeit so gerne macht der kurze
urlaub in den bergen an der see
der kurze ausflug zu verwandten dass all
das in diesem jahr über ostern nicht
stattfinden kann und gesagt das sind
harte wahrheiten und
das weiß sie weil wir natürlich gewinnen
sind uns frei zu bewegen und dass auch
ein teil unserer selbstentfaltung ist
aber genau das ist jetzt notwendig sie
hat sich an deutsche bürger gewandt ich
gehe davon aus dass das was der
niederländische ministerpräsident an die
bundesbürger gerichtet hat eher
umgekehrt sicherlich auch an seine
eigenen bürger
damit meint er sicherlich auch seine
eigenen bürger das liegt ja in der logik
der sache und ich glaube wir alle müssen
verstehen und da macht deutschland
niederlande oder andere länder keinen
großen unterschied dieses osterfest wird
ein anderes sein müssen
es ist ein osterfest im zeichen der
pandemie es ist ein osterfest in dem wir
unsere fürsorge unsere nächstenliebe
dadurch ausdrücken dass wir eben solche
reisen nicht machen um die infektions um
nicht neue infektionsherde zu schaffen
um die infektionszahlen nicht weiter
hochgehen zu lassen wir müssen sie
abflachen
dazu vielleicht noch ganz kurz ergänzen
dass wir ja bereits seit mitte märz eine
weltweite reisewarnung haben also von
nicht außen vor nicht notwendigen
touristischen reisen ins ausland ab
raten also dementsprechend auch von
reisen in die niederlande und daran
ändert sich jetzt über die osterzeit
nichts also von daher ist das absolut
auch die linie die wir hier unseren
bürgern empfehlen die niederländische
ministerpräsident da vorgetragen hat so
jetzt habe ich frau tish und henry dazu
ja und dann das war ja noch lockerung
und dann gehen wir mal zu meinem koffer
zu der app zurück der ist nämlich nicht
beantwortet die frage bis jetzt es ist
nicht an mir jetzt hier überraschung
oder so etwas auszudrücken die
bundeskanzlerin ist zurzeit nahezu
täglich mit vielen europäischen
regierungschefs im kontakt sie war auch
mit dem österreichischen regierungschef
im kontakt in den letzten tagen
ich habe das jetzt hier nicht zu
kommentieren unsere situation ist so wie
wir sie dargestellt haben
schickt er gerne noch etwas hinterher
der klägerin in höhe von der neuen
zürcher zeitung fragt wie wird diese
quarantäne pflicht begründet in einer
phase in der das virus auch in
deutschland ähnlich weit verbreitet ist
wie im rest europas und alle eu und
nachbarstaaten sehr ähnliche
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ergriffen haben
darf ich noch eins in richtung frau
höchst nachreichen ich glaube was man
auch bedenken muss ist dass österreich
zum teil strengere maßnahmen ergriffen
hatte als deutschland da gibt es dann
auch noch unterschiede von land zu land
aber das muss bei der ganzen sache
bedacht werden zu den grenzkontrollen
österreich zu sagen das hier ja schon
seit geraumer zeit auch schon vor
ausbruch der pandemie kontrolliert
worden ist aus anderen gründen
wir haben hier vorübergehende
grenzkontrollen das heißt es darf
niemand das land betreten ins land
einreisen der keinen wichtigen grund
vorzuweisen hat keinen dringenden reisen
und das ist so scharf wie das jetzt
erforderlich ist und weitere
verschärfungen sind jetzt nicht denkbar
das ist das was uns möglich ist und was
wir auch für völlig ausreichend erachten
so zu den übrigen grenzen
es ist entschieden worden dass wir zu
bestimmten ländern bestimmten
grenzregionen schweiz frankreich
luxemburg dänemark die vorübergehende
ganz tollen wie in österreich und
einführen
da hat gab es verschiedene gründe für
ein leitendes ein leitender grund war
dass sie ihre risikogebiete
gegeben hat oder gibt an den grenzen und
hier deswegen eine besondere
dringlichkeit war besonders
kontrollieren zu müssen
selbstverständlich spielt ja auch eine
rolle
inwieweit die länder dies für
erforderlich halten wir stehen in engem
austausch mit der landesregierung und
auch ein argument ist ob eine solche
massnahme befürwortet oder licht und zur
dritten frage quarantäne
wie wird die farbe mal ganz genau warum
also vom sinn her sind warum deutschland
jetzt einreisekontrollen oder macht
obwohl das in ganz europa von der gefahr
eigentlich ähnlich ist inzwischen die
bundesregierung wie bei ihren asam davon
bereitet nicht nur in deutschland die
infektionswege zu unterbrechen sondern
auch die infektionswege nach deutschland
unterscheiden wir nicht und insofern ist
es dem bundesminister sehr wichtig auch
hier voranzuschreiten und diese
quarantäne pflicht für die menschen
gehen und nach deutschland zurück
zurückkehren nach mehrtägigen
auslandsaufenthalt dient dazu weiterhin
auch die infektionsketten nach
deutschland zu unterbrechen und hier
noch weiter eine weitere verlangsamung
der virus ausbreitung zu erreichen habe
ich jetzt noch jemanden wegen grenz und
exit übersehen weil wir haben noch app
und die schaffung und wir haben auch
noch corona bonds winkel
es ist vorgesehen das
bundesgesundheitsministerium die flug
also firmen verpflichtet also die
flugunternehmen die passagierdaten an
die jeweils zuständige
gesundheitsbehörde weiterzugeben so dort
also dass dort kontrolliert werden kann
ob die der quarantäne folge geleistet
wird oder nicht
vorgesehen ist eine häusliche quarantäne
das heißt in diesem konkreten fall kann
der reisende dann nach in seine heimat
in seiner heimatstadt reisen um sich
dort direkt in quarantäne begeben und
das dies dass dies eingehalten wird wird
von der örtlichen gesundheitsbehörde
kontrolliert die entsprechenden
informationen durch die flugunternehmen
erhalten jetzt auch noch die frage hat
am triftigen grund auch aus ein
triftiger grund ist darunter fällt ein
dringender grund ist zum beispiel dass
man das gilt jetzt dringender grund für
die region wo jetzt schon vorübergehende
grenzkontrollen angeordnet worden sind
man kann dennoch einreisen wenn man zum
beispiel einen arbeitsvertrag nachweisen
nachweisen kann dass man alle pendler
als berufspendler oder einen
arbeitsauftrag in deutschland
auszuführen hat ein arbeitsvertrag
vorzuweisen hat das dann zum beispiel
dringende gründe dieser grenze hätte
jemand nicht mehr
dann kommen noch per kopf hat hat noch
mal das war zu der app könnte dazu
möchte ich will sie dich hindern was zu
sagen ja ich hab so ihre frage noch halb
im ok wunderbar es ging darum die app
gut also ich will nur mal ganz
grundsätzlich sagen das ist natürlich
ein ganz zentraler baustein wenn man
die ansteckungskette beim corona virus
senken will dass wir also wirklich im
infektionsfall in der lage sind die
kontakt ketten möglichst schnell zu
unterbrechen
das was bisher stattfand also das
analoge verfahren dass mitarbeiter eines
gesundheitsamts versuchten telefonisch
menschen zu erreichen die ihnen von
einem infizierten genannt worden sind
als seine kontakte
das kann bei diesem ausmaß der epidemie
natürlich nicht mehr die lösung sein es
kann sich auch niemand namentlich an
alle kontakte erinnern wir vielleicht im
bus oder so gehabt hat und deswegen
brauchen wir diese digitalen lösungen
und diese digitalen lösungen müssen
natürlich datenschutzrechtlich in fragen
der datensicherheit allen europäischen
und nationalen vorgaben genügen und ganz
wichtig wichtig sie müssen auf
europäischer ebene miteinander vereinbar
interoperabel sein
die bundesregierung begleitet die hielt
die entwicklung jetzt verschiedener
techniken und man muss da zwei dinge im
wesentlichen unterscheiden das eine ist
die frage nach einer deutschen app die
wird zurzeit entwickelt es gibt ein
prozess ein projekt mit dem heinrich
hertz institut und dem robert koch
institut gefördert vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium und das
andere ist die frage der europäischen
interoperabilität da gibt es einen
sogenannten multi nationalen pan
european privacy serving proximity
tracing ppt das soll die technische
rahmen architektur werden für
interoperable tracing apps in europa
daran sind 130 wissenschaftler aus
mehreren europäischen ländern beteiligt
als sprecher fungiert christian bos
mitglied des digital rats der
bundesregierung da sind auch mehrere
fraunhofer institute das rk ii die tu
berlin beteiligt und auch die haben
einen vielversprechenden ansatz damit
wir wirklich von einer
grenzüberschreitenden
funktion sprechen können der minister im
kanzleramt helge braun hat heute morgen
in einer fernsehsendung gesagt wir
brauchen das in jedem fall eu-weit das
schlimmste wäre wenn wir nun sozusagen
viele verschiedene tracking apps in
europa hätten was deutschland betrifft
hat er gesagt dass man mit entwicklern
und testern dabei sei die app so reif zu
kriegen dass wir sie in den kommenden
tagen oder wochen breit in der
bevölkerung zum einsatz bringen können
und dann noch der letzte satz dazu weil
er ganz ganz wichtig ist diese app soll
freiwillig eingesetzt werden
freiwilligkeit ist die grundlage der
verwendung dieser app natürlich von der
seite der bundesregierung und auch von
der seite der srk ihn natürlich mit der
hoffnung verbunden dass möglichst viele
menschen diese app freiwillig nutzen
werden denn dann wird sie ihre beste
wirkung entfalten
ich kann ihnen das ehrlich gesagt nicht
beziffern
ich denke aber dass die argumente für
diese app und das immer wieder zu
erwähnen de argument der freiwilligkeit
trotzdem so groß sind dass vielleicht
wenn sie dann auf dem markt ist doch
sehr viele menschen sich überlegen
werden dass sie in dem sie diese app
nutzen sie keinerlei daten rechtliches
risiko eingehen aber sie wirklich einen
nennenswerten beitrag leisten dazu dass
wir die infektionsketten unterbrechen
können und mittelfristig die
ansteckungskette wirklich besser in den
bric in den griff bekommen ich habe
jetzt dazu ein junger und herrenberg und
noch von daniel böcking die frage helge
braun hatte sich unter
kanzleramtsminister hatte sich
unterschiedlich geäußert einmal hat er
von wochen gesprochen bis die app da ist
und einmal von tagen
da fragt er nach wie die zeit
perspektive ist und fragt auch nach ob
es sich um die jenaer app oder eine
andere entwicklung handelt nein nina ist
ja wenn ich das sagen dafür etwas
anderes nina ist die app des bundesamtes
für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe bbk eine sehr
nützliche app für jeden der schnelle
informationen über die korona pandemie
und ihren weg durch unser land haben
will ist das eine sehr empfohlene app
aber das ist nicht die tracing app über
die ich jetzt hier kurz gesprungen wäre
das auch erklärt herr jung hat das wort
und er trinke habe ich dann auch der
liste
bbk
was jetzt das sind antworten die würde
ich ihnen weil es doch sehr ins detail
geht auch ins technische und digitale
gelegt würde ich ihnen gerne nach
reichen nicht aus dem kopf
das ist jetzt nicht so richtig erwähnt
also ich beantwortet es gerne die
bundeskanzlerin macht seit mindestens 12
13 jahren jedes wochenende einen
video-podcast
und so war es auch am vergangenen also
es gab schon immer in dieser
kanzlerschaft nahezu immer einen
wochenendlichen video podcast und genau
das gibt es auch weiterhin und heute
nachmittag gibt es einen pressetermin im
kanzleramt
und ich würde mir jetzt nicht so gerne
die fragen einer struktur hier aus der
hand nehmen lassen
das war hier am vergangenen freitag
thema der bundespressekonferenz ist klar
beantwortet worden würde ich sie bitten
im protokoll nachzuschauen ist ein sehr
guter vorschlag
ich kann ihnen keine technischen keine
details zu nennen wir können das im
zweifelsfall nachreichen
ja ich würde auch jetzt die die
technischen einzelfragen zur entwicklung
dieses european privacy pries irving
proximity tracing würde ich ihnen gerne
nachreichen
kann dem nächsten europäischen rat im
video konferenz format hier nicht
vorgreifen aber ich gebe ihnen trotzdem
gerne reiche eben trotzdem gerne in der
antwort nach dann hab ich jetzt frau bot
zum thema nochmal also ich habe auf
meiner liste noch das thema corona bonds
oder wie immer die auch heißen frau pohl
asse von der italienische kollegin von
der nachrichtenagentur ansa fragt was
hält die bundesregierung von dem band
elo die briten vorschlag briten
vorschlag die eu kommission haben einen
von der langfristige anleihen ausgibt
vorgeschlagen und wird der europäische
rat noch diese woche stattfinden
sie haben tun
vielen dank also die zu dem thema haben
wir jetzt ja schon oft gesprochen der
minister wird er gleich eine
pressekonferenz geben und ich denke da
kann man ihnen auch noch mal fragen zu
der europäischen dimension der hilfe die
wir leisten die heute zusammen mit dem
außenminister auch einen gastbeitrag
herausgegeben wurde noch einmal betont
dass wir eine gemeinsame solidarische
antwort auf die krise brauchen hat
konkrete vorschläge gemacht wie diese
hilfe aussehen kann darüber ist er
gerade mit seinen europäischen partnern
im gespräch wird dann am dienstag eine
telefonkonferenz machen mit den partnern
aus der euro-gruppe erweiterten format
und wird sich danach auch dazu äußern
und dann werden die finanzministerien
und finanzminister den europäischen rat
einen vorschlag machen ich kann nur
diese frage nach dem europäischen rat
ganz kurz beantworten das ist natürlich
die einladung eine sache des präsidenten
des europäischen rates star michelle und
es liegt bisher keine neue einladung zu
einer video konferenz vor ich habe noch
einen jugend zum thema opec
ich kann das gerne ganz kurz beantworten
wie üblich nehmen wir keine
kommentierung zur opec verhandlung
vorstellen auch keine ölpreisprognosen
aber ich kann ihnen sagen dass die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
gewährleistet ist ich kommentiere das
nicht
die kollegin hat sich daraus gesprochen
und ich habe dem nichts hinzuzufügen
und dann habe ich noch frisch und herrn
lang am ufer weiter ich habe komplett
vergessen schmücken
dazu haben wir ja schon verschiedentlich
von dieser stelle ausgesprochen
ziel der bundesregierung auch des
bundesinnenministers ist es hier
schnellstmöglich eine humanitäre lösung
zu finden für die in unsere kinder aus
den flüchtlingslagern die eu kommission
hat hier auch auf drängen des
bundesinnenministers die koordinierung
übernommen die fläche werden geführt
auch im hintergrund mit denen im kreis
der staaten die sich da bereit erklärt
haben
auch da ist der bundesinnenminister sehr
aktiv und wir hoffen dass sehr zeitnah
hier konkret gehandelt werden kann von
unserer seite aus
liegt da alles erforderliche vor es ist
in verschiedene stellen die hier
zusammen arbeiten nicht nur die eu
kommission sondern auch die un oder der
usa
die technischen abstimmungen laufen und
es wird auch morgen eine weitere
telefonkonferenz der zuständigen eu
kommissaren mit den mitgliedstaaten mit
den innenministern der mitgliedstaaten
geben die sich bereit erklärt haben
also es läuft wir arbeiten mit hochdruck
daran und sind zuversichtlich dass wir
im europäischen verbund hier bald eine
lösung hinbekommen
was reif und das als nordischer seit
mehreren wochen haben sie die 40 kreis
aus oder judo bundes investiert
wiederholt deutlich gemacht dass für ihn
ein vorgehen im europäischen gleichklang
von äußerster wichtigkeit ist es ist nun
aufgabe der eu kommission die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen die
gespräche zu einem guten ende zu führen
wir sind hier sehr optimistisch dass wir
bald fortschritte sehen
dazu mein name ist luxemburg zehn kinder
auf der bundesinnenminister hat
wiederholt deutlich gemacht dass ihm ein
europäisches vorgehen hier sehr wichtig
ist im europäischen gleichklang deswegen
koordinierte eu kommission führt der
ernsthafte gespräche wir unterstützen
hier im hintergrund sehr intensiv
einfach an der bundesinnenminister und
wir gehen davon aus dass wir zeitnah
eine europäische lösung hinbekommen
das ist die position von deutschland 1
jung habe ich noch dazu und dann habe
ich noch frisch und kein ring oder habe
ich das nie geschafft
also ja aber das ganz schnell wären noch
2 das ist ein thema das die
bundeskanzlerin bewegt wie es die
bundesregierung insgesamt bewegt der
innenminister ist wie sein sprecher ja
gerade gesagt hat da sehr engagiert auch
hinter den europäischen kulissen und wir
hoffen und haben aber auch den
optimismus dass es eben eine zeitnahe
lösung eine europäische lösung geben
wird
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht was
sie mit diesem begriff meinen wie alles
was wichtig ist beschäftigt dass auch
die bundeskanzlerin die dieser
bundesregierung vor sitzt ja
die flecker nicht dazu was sagen also
die sofort hilfen des bundes für die
gewährung von überbrückungshilfen werden
elektronikriese werden für unternehmen
und solo selbständige zur verfügung
gestellt und stehen selbstverständlich
auch gemeinnützigen organisationen offen
voraussetzung ist jedoch dass der
antragsteller wirtschaftlich und damit
dauerhaft am markt als unternehmen tätig
ist und die wsf also die unterstützung
durch den durch den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds bzw
die sonderkredite dürfen aufgrund der
gemeinnützigkeit und auch aufgrund der
größen kriterien dagegen ausscheiden der
investitionskredit kommunale und soziale
unternehmen der kfw ermöglicht aber
kommunalen unternehmen und
gemeinnützigen organisationen eine
zinsgünstige und langfristige
finanzierung von investitionen in die
kommunale und soziale infrastruktur
sowie bis 30 12 2020 auch die
finanzierung von betriebsmitteln
alle weiteren auf die uhr also alle
weiteren fragen die zu finanziellen
belangen sind die können der kann sicher
der finanzminister sofort im anschluss
blenden beantworten
ich bitte um nachsicht für alle die ich
vielleicht übersehen haben und die
nichts wort gekommen sind und danke
herzlich den regierungssprechern und den
sprechern und sprechern der ministerien
dass sie gekommen sind und unsere fragen
beantwortet haben und später die
pressekonferenz
es schließt sich die pressekonferenz mit
finanzminister schäuble und
bundeswirtschaftsminister gleich hier an
danke